I'm gonna need you to back up and move
over Big Willie because your better half
will be the center of attention Monday
night at the MTV Movie and TV Awards
Jade is receiving the coveted
Trailblazer award and here's what else
you can expect from the most
unpredictable award show of them all
it's popcorn it's gold anything it's
golden popcorn ahh ahh
who's your secret little thing you did
to prepare to be ready to host this show
go in the gym trust in God I don't know
what the actual night is gonna feel like
other than it's like jumping out of a
plane which I also kind of like doing so
I don't know really I'm just a glutton
for punishment that's what it
Sakura's been prepping for a month now
getting ready to host the show for the
first time ever he's taking over for
Tiffany Haddish who did the honors last
year did you call TIFF to get aim kind
of tip I was gonna say yeah I've called
Tiffany repeatedly she just won't return
my calls but that's not true I don't
have her phone number
Haddish hit me Shazam is also up for two
awards including best hero
and Dwayne the rock Johnson will be
honored with the Generation Award but
what we're really hoping to see a little
singing action from Zachary on stage you
did a really cool thing you went and
visited young lady who was sick and you
sang to her real she happened to be a
tango fan and her mom was like sing a
song and I was like okay here we go
you know and it was lovely was so it was
all totally impromptu I had no idea was
gonna happen and I was just grateful
that I got to have that moment with her
you know I think that was really special
[Music]
[Applause]